bleep grannies farts alone been told
it's got a lot of vitamin D well stop
[Music]
high lad Bible
what are you ready hi I'm Jack Black I'm
here to answer some of your life advice
questions and give you some life advice
my girlfriend
dog breaks into our room when we're
having some alone time I hate it but my
girlfriend isn't fazed should I be
worried about her Adam from Essex she
doesn't mind that the dogies watch the
the bacon being made whatever gets you
rocks up well I don't think there's
anything wrong with that it's only
nature mmm sorry sorry sorry bro yeah
good no oh dang I almost took your head
off I'm gonna be a lawsuit by the end of
this thing I've got my aunt coming over
for Christmas but all she does is fart
and eat oh that's so sexy how do I make
my excuse to get out of the house for
Christmas um get over your fear of
flatulence leap grannies farts alone
granny fart all she wants but uh okay
better out than in
let her rip this Christmas sorry I
didn't I injured a guy with my boyfriend
has been pushing me to try role-playing
in the bedroom have you given it a go
and if so any tips Ashley from Bedford
um yeah I've done a little bit of
role-playing like maintenance dude is my
go-to for some reason
what yeah I come to clean the pipes
I heard you got a problem with the pipes
it's a good one you should try that way
I keep falling asleep stood up on the
dance floor when I'm being going out I
gotta learn to read did that make sense
I keep falling asleep stood up on the
dance floor when I've been going out any
recommendations on how to stop this Joe
from Manchester
huh hi stiff cup of joe yeah densey boy
from Camden thinking a booking a holiday
to Argentina do you have any
recommendations oh yeah I've never been
Argentina but I heard the stakes are
magnificent they say the best in the
world knows no knows why they're bovines
are so delish get a steak
that's my Breton recommendation my old
mates have been picking on me for a
while
because I'm the smallest in the youngest
how do I tell them to stop Richard from
hair for Shire loudly like try this one
out stop Wow stop in my trash
mmm you guys thank you for listening to
my advice I know it wasn't all good
advice they came from here Mohawk
welcome to the jungle thank you
[Music]